buonasera buonasera mi chiamo martina
recchiuti lavora internazionale e vorrei
parlarvi di come la tecnologia sta
cambiando il modo in cui giornali
distribuiscano le notizie
quando tre settimane fa abbiamo deciso
di pubblicare in copertina un reportage
a fumetti di zero calcare non pensavamo
che il numero sarebbe andato esaurito
nel giro di poche ore
in realtà avevamo avuto dei segnali
qualche giorno prima infatti avevano
pubblicato sulle nostre pagine facebook
twitter youtube e google plus un video
che presentava il fumetto e annunciava
l'uscita in edicola
era un breve trailer con una musica di
sottofondo molto rock
era quello che nella stanza chiamiamo un
bustino una parola strana che viene dall
inglese boost che significa spinta per
noi nella stanza un bustino è un
contenuto capace di generare in breve
tempo parecchio traffico sul nostro sito
in effetti appena abbiamo pubblicato il
video su facebook ha subito ricevuto
migliaia di dike di condivisioni e
decine di commenti
in particolare su facebook ha innescato
a quello strano meccanismo per cui nei
commenti
c'era solo una lunga lista di nomi e
cognomi segno che le persone stavano
condividendo il video con i loro amici
quando il numero uscito in edicola
qualche giorno dopo abbiamo subito
ricevuto i miei commenti su facebook
segnalazioni di lettori che però in
realtà abbiamo capito non erano più solo
i nostri lettori perché si erano
mescolati ai fan di zero calcare e tutti
si chiedevano come fare per trovare il
numero perché apparentemente non si
trova più
se ne dica è tutta italia e addirittura
abbiamo scoperto che qualcuno ne aveva
messo in vendita una copia su ebay a 350
euro
pensate che internazionale dei costa 3 e
c'era un'offerta per questo in modo un
po un repentino abbiamo deciso di
ristampare il fumetto e di allegarlo
gratuitamente al numero successivo prima
ancora di avere dati ufficiali della
distribuzione
prima di sapere se il numero era
effettivamente andato esaurito
abbiamo deciso di correre il rischio di
questa ristampa fondamentalmente forse
per la prima volta la strada
internazionale
basandoci sulle reazioni dei commenti su
fede
gli elettori su facebook e sui dati di
chartbeat chartbeat non so se lo
conoscete è un software progettato in
un'azienda di new york e lo usiamo in
redazione per sapere all'istante quante
persone sono sul sito e cosa stanno
leggendo e quel giorno i dati ci
dicevano che i lettori erano tutti sulla
pagina del sito di internazionale che
parlava dell'uscita del fumetto
tutto questo non sarebbe mai potuto
accadere dieci anni fa prima di facebook
prima di char bit o prima ancora di
internet prima di internet infatti i
giornalisti non avevano la minima idea
di quante persone avessero letto un loro
articolo
poi nei primi anni di internet i
giornalisti avevano accesso a questi
dati giorni o addirittura settimane dopo
che l'articolo era stato pubblicato ora
invece lo sanno subito sanno quante
persone stanno leggendo il loro articolo
sanno quanto tempo rimangono sulla
pagina sano dollari da dove arrivano
sono addirittura si stanno leggendo
l'articolo da un computer da un tablet o
uno smartphone sanno se dopo aver letto
l'articolo ne leggono un altro oppure se
vanno via ciardi te solo uno degli
strumenti che offre questi tipi di
diciamo analisi in tempo reale ma
strumenti come ciardi offrono oggi ai
giornali un pozzo di dati che se
analizzati con cura possono migliorare
notevolmente la qualità del nostro
lavoro
vi faccio un esempio se per esempio noi
scopriamo che un articolo a tantissime
visualizzazioni tantissimi clienti in
questo momento quindi apparentemente
all'articolo più letto in questo momento
però in realtà un tempo di permanenza
bassissimo significa di pochi secondi
significa che qualcosa è andato storto
forse perché appunto i lettori hanno
letto magari due righe sono andati via
forse il titolo era sbagliato forse il
lancio era stato scritto male forse
l'attacco la era noioso in ogni caso un
fallimento se invece per esempio un
video sull'ucraina a molti a molti meno
click però il tempo di permanenza più
alto significa che i lettori lo stanno
guardando fino in fondo e questo
ovviamente è un grandissimo successo non
solo per il video sull'ucraina ma anche
perché noi sappiamo che se le persone
vedono un video per più di un minuto
crescono potenzialmente
le possibilità che decidono poi di
condividerlo con altri lettori
attraverso i social network e sta
studiando i dati appunto noi sappiamo
che tutti i lettori che arrivano su un
giornale sui mezzi di informazione
passando dall home page sono i lettori
più fedeli sono quelli che rimangono più
a lungo
tornano più spesso in genere leggono più
di tre articoli
sappiamo che chi arriva da facebook è
più attento e disposto a partecipare ma
torna molto più raramente
sappiamo per esempio che chi arriva da
twitter ha un atteggiamento molto più
mordi e fuggi sono lettori che arrivano
molto velocemente leggono un articolo e
scappano ma magari ritornano spesso ma
non leggono mai quasi quasi mai più di
un articolo e poi sappiamo che c'è il
traffico di google news con traffico
molto particolare perché riesce google
news riesce a riportare in vita anche
articoli pubblicati un anno fa studiamo
per esempio questi dati e noi possiamo
scoprire che siamo rubrica pop come per
esempio l'oroscopo l'oroscopo di rho
bresnik e pubblichiamo sono rubrica sta
facendo moltissimo traffico passante i
lettori arrivano tutti da facebook
noi possiamo decidere di non darle
visibilità in home page
perché tanto sta già facendo traffico da
sola e possiamo decidere di lasciare
quello spazio per una notizia magari più
marginale ma in realtà
giornalisticamente più interessante come
per esempio il video sull'ucraina la
cosa più interessante è la cosa più
buffa più buffa forse che abbiamo
scoperto studiando i dati del nostro
sito e che i nostri lettori leggono gli
articoli più lunghi
il reportage da 80 mila battute per
intenderci sono veramente lunghissimi
non tanto da un computer o da un tablet
ma da un telefono abbiamo pensato che
probabilmente lo fa da uno smartphone
abbiamo pensato che probabilmente
leggono questi articoli la mattina
mentre si spostano per andare
all'università o in ufficio magari
utilizzando i mezzi pubblici con la
metropolitana oppure la sera prima di
andare a dormire
e visto che ci siamo resi conto che i
nostri lettori hanno un rapporto così
privilegiato diciamo con lo smartphone
abbiamo pensato perché non aprire una
sezione di audio documentari sul sito
d'altronde l'audio sembra fatto apposta
per il telefono
a ferrara al festival di giornalismo che
organizziamo ogni anno proiettiamo
presentiamo una serie di diciamo i
migliori audio documentari in giro per
il mondo e sono in lingua originale in
inglese e le persone fanno educatamente
la fila per ascoltarli per entrare nelle
salette del castello di ferrara e
ascoltare questi documentari oggi
provare a replicare un'esperienza del
genere online non è né particolarmente
complicato né particolarmente costoso
basta infatti contattare l'autore del
documentario contrattare i diritti di
riproduzione
farsi mandare il file originale con un
servizio di file sharing gratuito tipo
wetransfer e caricare l'audio originale
sul sito con un sito e gestione audio
tipo soundcloud
non bisogna più costruire in casa delle
piattaforme particolarmente complicate o
molto costose perché è già tutto su
internet e ci si può abbonare per pochi
dollari al mese
non sappiamo se i nostri lettori se la
sezione degli audio per documentari
avere successo non sappiamo se veramente
c'è un pubblico di lettori che ha voglia
di ascoltare un odio documentare un
inglese la mattina mentre era in
metropolitana in ufficio però abbiamo
pensato che quello che possiamo fare è
semplicemente sperimentare fare un test
scegliere 45 audio documentari caricarli
sul sito controllare dati e vedere i
risultati
quello che sicuramente sappiamo inoltre
è che cercheremo di presentare questa
nuova rubrica ai nostri lettori con lo
stesso metodo con cui presentiamo su
facebook e su twitter e sui social
network ogni articolo che pubblichiamo
ogni volta che lanciamo un articolo su
facebook su twitter noi scriviamo il
titolo è il sottotitolo il lanciano
scusatemi
lo scriviamo il machete interna che
usiamo in redazione per condividere le
informazioni in modo che tutti nella
stanza possono leggere il titolo
modificarla ed eventualmente commentarlo
lo scriviamo il loro modifichiamo in
modo che sia veloce da leggere semplice
e chiaro
a quel punto scegliamo
una volta che abbiamo trovato il lancio
giusto scegliamo una una bella foto la
ottimizziamo per il web infatti ormai su
internet sono le breaking news possono
permettersi di viaggiare senza
un'immagine qualunque altro articolo ha
bisogno di una fotografia o di un
immagine per essere diciamo per piacere
all'algoritmo di facebook e di gonews e
quindi per assicurarsi una maggiore
visibilità e a quel punto con il lancio
è l'immagine giusta lancia pubblichiamo
l'articolo su facebook che andiamo a
controllare i dati teniamo d'occhio dati
un'altra delle cose che teniamo sempre
d'occhio sono i commenti dei nostri
lettori su facebook e su twitter non
tutti sono estremamente interessanti non
tutti portano valore aggiunto alla
conversazione alcuni secondo me sono
abbastanza inutili però li leggiamo
sempre tutti quanti rispondiamo ogni
volta che un lettore ci chiede
un'informazione o ci aiuta nella diciamo
all'assessore all'articolo ci dà dei
suggerimenti
ho l'impressione che le persone non si
rendono ben conto del tono che usano sui
social network e spesso firmano con il
loro nome e cognome delle frasi che
magari non ti direbbero mai di persona e
trovo che tutto questo sia molto ingenuo
perché in realtà una delle prime cose
che facciamo quando incontriamo una
persona magari per un colloquio di
lavoro o per una collaborazione
qualunque e andare a dare una
sbirciatina ai suoi social network a un
tumblr on twitter una pagina su facebook
per vedere il modo in cui loro si
presentano online e infatti anche per
questo negli stati uniti sono nati
servizi come fim cup che è un sito che
analizza le frasi che usiamo di più sui
social network e ci aiuta a comportarci
meglio in ogni caso noi abbiamo deciso
con il lancio di internet del nuovo sito
l'internazionale di togliere i commenti
dal nostro sito molto banalmente la
nostra non ha una grande redazione e
avremo bisogno di una persona che si
occupi di moderare i commenti a tempo
pieno e avevo preferito investire su una
persona che scrive le notizie a tempo
pieno non siamo l'unico giornale ad aver
fatto questa scelta infatti anche il new
york times l'anno scorso ha deciso di
togliere i commenti dalle notizie di
diciamo di stretta attualità e di
lasciarli solo sotto le opinioni
chiedendo però all'autore dell'articolo
di partecipare alla discussione ed
eventualmente di moderare i commenti
oppure lasciando i commenti aperti sotto
sotto solo sotto alcuni articoli in ogni
caso il new york times pensate c'è una
squadra formata da una decina di
moderatori che leggono 11 tutti i
commenti prima di pubblicarli anche la
reuters l'anno scorso ha deciso di
togliere i commenti perché secondo loro
ormai le conversazioni si sono spostate
diciamo sui social network una buona
notizia però che viene dal mondo dei
commenti e che l'anno scorso il new york
times il washington post hanno firmato
un accordo con la mozilla foundation per
progettare entro i prossimi due anni
un nuovo una nuova piattaforma per i
commenti dei lettori ai contributi dei
lettori e quando sarà pronta fra un paio
d'anni la metteranno gratuitamente a
disposizione di tutti i giornali che
vorranno usarla
un altro esempio interessante che viene
dal mondo dei commenti è quello di medio
non so se lo conoscete è un sito che
pubblica dove è possibile pubblicare dei
contenuti a metà tra un post in un
articolo sul medium in realtà non è
possibile inserire un generico mi piace
non mi piace un commento ma se sei
registrato puoi commentare puoi
aggiungere una nota sotto ogni singolo
paragrafo l'autore dell'articolo poi
deciderà se il rendere pubblica quella
nota anche in quel caso apparirà proprio
accanto al paragrafo oppure se
rispondere privatamente alla persona che
gli ha mandato il commento magari
ringraziandolo per la segnalazione di un
refuso e diciamo per il momento abbiamo
tolto i commenti ma sotto ogni articolo
abbiamo un tasto che si chiama appunto
commenti e suggerimenti per mandare un'e
mail alla redazione e quindi comunque
per partecipare alla discussione per
commentare lo stesso in un altro modo
l'articolo però non è detto che magari
fra un paio d'anni e decideremo di
adottare la piattaforma di medium la
piattaforma della mozilla foundation
d'altronde su internet le cose cambiano
molto velocemente per cui fra sei mesi
potremmo decidere di cambiare nuovamente
tutto quanto
nell'ultimo anno sul sito
l'internazionale abbiamo avuto una
grande accelerazione
abbiamo chiesto a un grafico britannico
mark porter che lavora a londra uno
studio a londra di progettare il nostro
nuovo sito e di seguirci non lo sviluppo
di alcune app che vogliamo appunto
progettare per permettere di leggere in
maniera diversa i nostri articoli online
e sul sito oggi lavorano persone erano
competenze molto diverse abbiamo per
esempio 3 programmatori due foto editor
che si occupa non solo della scelta
delle fotografie un copy editor che si
occupa di mantenere lo stile degli
articoli sia sempre perfetto abbiamo una
persona che si occupa solo di grafici e
tabelle un tecnico che si occupa del
montaggio video
abbiamo due correttrice di bozze che non
sono mai abbastanza
e chissà forse magari in futuro avremo
anche uno di quei ruoli divertenti che
si leggono sulle pagine del new york
times tipo direttore della homepage
mobile o sviluppatore di notizie
interattive per la cronaca io sogno
tantissimo di diventare direttrice delle
ultime file e se c'è qualcuno di voi in
questa stanza che sogna di fare un
lavoro tipo questo che potrebbe essere
appunto un lavoro che viene che a metà
tra tra giornalismo e comunicazione e
tecnologia ci sono tre cose che mi
piacerebbe consigliargli la prima è di
fare tantissimi test ed esperimenti
pensate per esempio che nella redazione
del guardian un giornale britannico
hanno un intera intero laboratorio
noiosa venite lab dove pieno di computer
smartphone e desktop di destra no e
tablet di qualunque tipo e modello dove
ero praticamente attestano in
continuazione il modo in cui le persone
usano il loro sito e le loro app per
cercare di migliorarla
quando sono andata a trovarle un paio di
mesi fa stavano addirittura facendo
delle dei test con i smartwatch lo smart
di smartphones come davide prati
fondamentalmente ti comunicanti arrivano
a notifica quando ricevi un'email o un
messaggio sul telefono e coniglio che
insomma per che state facendo dei test
sugli smartphone ciò che serve non hanno
risposto guarda veramente non ne abbiamo
idea però comunque vogliamo fare un test
perché non vogliamo farci trovare
impreparati quando in futuro se in
futuro le notifiche sugli smart watch
diventeranno una cosa gigante quindi gli
esperimenti in continuazione
un'altra cosa che vi consiglio di fare e
di ascoltare sempre il vostro pubblico i
vostri lettori e quindi di leggere i
commenti
commenti per esempio che arrivano in
redazione come per esempio a catania non
riusciamo a trovare il vostro numero da
nessuna parte oppure ho provato ad
abbonarti a donarmi sul sito online ma
non ci riesco solo per noi di
fondamentale importanza quindi la pagina
facebook deve essere veramente uno
strumento di vera interazione che nei
lettori ma l'ultimo consiglio che mi
l'ultimo consiglio che mi permetto di
darvi è quello di guardare sempre cosa
fanno gli altri più bravi e di cercare
di imparare da loro il più possibile nel
nostro caso per esempio guardiamo sempre
con attenzione il modo in cui il new
york times cerca di interagire con i
suoi lettori il modo in cui la radio
pubblica americana npr il tono con cui
la radio pubblica americana in p er
presenta i nuovi audio documentari sul
suo sito le app che guardian mette a
disposizione e progetta per permettere
ai lettori di leggere notizie sul
telefono o anche semplicemente il modo
in cui l'agenzia americana
corregge pubblicamente i suoi errori su
twitter
vorrei concludere questo breve discorso
raccontandovi in particolare di un libro
che ha letto tempo fa e che ha trovato
molto divertente
c'era una persona che sarebbe diventata
di lì a breve un futuro pezzo grosso
della silicon valley e gli avevano
offerto un lavoro da google ma lei non
sapeva se accettarla o meno perché
sarebbe stato a capo di una divisione
che in realtà non era ancora stata messa
in piedi non esisteva ancora e quindi
non sapeva se accettarla o meno
e allora un altro pezzo grosso di google
e disse quando qualcuno ti offre un
posto sul razzo non chiederti di che
posso si tratti sali e basta
a volte penso che un po questa l'aria
che si respira in certe redazioni oggi
grazie